Yeah, let's unpack this.
Imagine for a moment not not a
country exactly, but this huge,
sprawling, neon lit casino.
And it's way Wilder, I mean,
more chaotic and frankly much
more profitable than anything
you probably ever seen.
That's the the striking analogy
really at the heart of the
sources we've been diving into
this idea of America as the
world's casino.
So our mission today really is
to get out of the hood of that,
understand why this analogy
seems to fit according to these
sources.
You know, who are the players in
this this massive game?
How is it actually played?
And maybe the biggest question,
what is it all mean for you,
whether you even realize you're,
you know, sitting at the table
or not?
Because look, this horses make
it clear, this isn't Vegas.
He's not polished tables and
watchful dealers know.
They call it the Wild West of
casinos, a place where, and I'm
quoting here, the doors never
close and the rules are written
in pencil.
It's just constant action built
for it.
Yeah.
And what's really fascinating, I
think, is that core argument you
touched on in this particular
casino volatility, you know, the
ups and downs, the chaos.
It isn't some like, unfortunate
bug.
It is the product that's what's
being bought and sold.
And we're going to explore how
that idea, that fundamental
concept sort of reshapes how we
look at everything, politics,
finance, even, you know, your
own savings.
And along the way, yeah, we'll
definitely meet the players.
The sources identify the
hustlers, the often unknowing
marks, the real pros, and this
really interesting idea that the
house itself is kind of asleep.
Volatility is the product.
That's a powerful way to frame
it, so let's jump right in.
Where do the sources first take
us to really flush out this
idea?
America as this place where
instability is, is actually
monetized.
Where volatility is the product,
not a side effect.
Well, they're pretty direct.
They call America the biggest
and wildest casino ever built,
like an open air palace of
volatility.
It's a very vivid image.
And you know, you think of a
normal casino, right?
Yeah.
Polished tables, dealers
watching everything, cameras,
all that control, trying to keep
things fair or at least
predictable.
Orderly.
Almost.
Exactly.
But this American casino, the
sources painted as the the
complete opposite.
Here, the hustlers run free, the
marks outnumber the pros 1000 to
1.
And the pit bosses?
Well, they're too busy counting
their own chips to really care
what's happening on the floor.
Right.
So it's chaotic by design,
almost.
And what really makes it
different, they argue, is how
opportunity works.
It's not just about placing a
bet.
They say everything.
Every spin of the wheel, every
fluctuation in the market, every
scandal, every election, every
war and every rumor.
It's not just an event, and it
becomes a new chance to extract
wealth.
Always.
It's relentless, just this
constant stream of chances to
profit born right out of that
instability.
I mean, just think about being
inside that.
If you don't know the rules, or
or maybe you don't even know
you're in a casino, it must just
feel like turbulence, constant,
uncertain.
Absolutely.
And building right on that, the
sources make this crucial
distinction.
It's really central to
everything they're saying in
America, volatility is not a
side effect.
It is the product.
And that's not just, you know, a
clever phrase.
It's fundamental.
It means the very instability,
the unpredictability most people
try to, you know, smooth out or
avoid.
That's precisely what others are
looking to trade, to package, to
sell.
And the sources get into the
specifics of how this volatility
is sort of systematically
generated and then exploited.
Like, take political cycles.
They call the four year
presidential cycle a slot
machine on steroids.
Wow.
Every election isn't just, you
know, choosing leaders.
It's a wild card.
It swings markets globally.
It can trigger global panic or
euphoria.
And the impact isn't slow.
It's like boom, instantaneous
huge shifts in value you can bet
on.
And it's not just the big
elections, right?
They mentioned smaller things.
Oh yeah, even like a single
tweet can erase billions or 1:00
speech can pump stocks to the
moon.
It just shows you how sensitive
the system is, how quickly
information, even just, you
know, informal chatter, can have
these massive financial ripple
effects, which of course makes
having the right information
fast incredibly valuable.
And it feels like this isn't
just accidental.
The way they describe it, it
sounds like the the very
structure of the country, it's
politics, it's culture, it's all
kind of geared towards this.
They say our politics are a
pendulum, our culture is a tide,
and our economy is an experiment
in perpetual risk.
So this constant flux isn't a
mistake.
It's it's part of the engine.
It creates the opportunities.
Exactly.
They just did it.
Really.
Clearly the markets are volatile
because they're supposed to be.
It's not a problem needing a
fix, it's the mechanism itself.
They use this great analogy.
Volatility is the oxygen that
fuels the fire, the thing
traders can package, slice and
sell.
That's the core idea right
there.
Instability isn't just
weathered, it's actively turned
into a commodity, packaged up
into complex financial products,
leveraged, sold.
It's really something to think
about instability as the actual
product.
Yeah, it is pretty chilling when
you frame it that way, reframing
risk as a commodity.
So, OK, what does this actually
mean for, you know, the average
person for a listener, maybe
because for most of us, that
inherent volatility that
designed in chaos, it probably
feels like being on a boat in a
storm constantly.
It's unsettling.
But for a select few, as the
sources say, it's not a storm at
all.
No, it's opportunity.
It's a gold mine, the players in
the stakes, who's playing and
who's being played.
Right.
So volatility is the product and
chaos is kind of the engine
room.
The next obvious question the
sources tackle is, OK, who are
the ones actually doing the
buying and selling?
Who's profiting?
And they call them the smart
ones, the connected ones, the
ones who understand the
machinery.
Not your average Joe investor
then.
Definitely not.
Yeah, these are the the real
masters of this game.
They list them out the rest of
the world's billionaires, hedge
fund managers, sovereign wealth
funds and corporate sharks.
You know, entities with huge
amounts of capital,
sophisticated networks, deep,
deep understanding of how
markets really work.
And for these players, America
is described as well, perfect.
The perfect environment.
Why?
They point to things like open
markets, minimal barriers, and
this underlying culture addicted
to consumption.
It's almost like the system was
practically designed for their
specific strategies.
Yeah, they even use the term
economic alchemy.
They say if they could have
designed a place to turn lead
into gold, they would have
designed America.
It is economic alchemy.
Raw inputs go in, chaos gets
stirred and profit pours out.
You're really potent image,
right?
Creating wealth seemingly out of
thin air, out of the very
turbulence others fear.
And this is where you really see
the casino mechanics laid bare.
The sources explain how these
smart players actually profit
from the chaos.
It's not just surviving it, it's
exploiting it.
Every terrible thing that
happens here, every crash, every
scandal, every bubble popping
becomes a chance to win bigger.
So they're not just reacting,
they're actively looking for the
angles and bad news.
Precisely, and they give some
really stark examples.
A natural disaster.
The advice is short insurance
stocks bet on them falling.
A corporate collapse.
The play is buy the bonds at
pennies on the dollar, hoping
for recovery or liquidation
value.
A trade war?
You hedge the volatility, buy
the dip and sell the rebound.
It's this relentless
opportunistic mindset applied to
every single market tremor,
basically weaponizing bad news.
And the financial tools they
use, The machinery behind this
sounds incredibly complex.
Oh, absolutely.
They stress that the system lets
them profit on the way up, make
money on the way down, and make
even more money on the
turbulence in between.
So it's not just about writing a
rising market, it's about making
money from any movement.
Exactly, and the sources list
the arsenal, futures, options,
swaps, derivatives.
Maybe we should quickly clarify
some of those.
Good idea.
So derivatives very simply are
contracts whose value comes from
something else, like a stock
price.
They let you bet on where that
price is going without owning
the stock itself.
OK.
Futures and options are just
specific types of those
contracts.
Swaps involve exchanging
financial instruments and then
you have algorithmic trades in
microseconds.
That's high speed computers
making trades faster than any
human could react.
Got it.
Speed and complexity.
Right.
And long bets that stretch over
decades.
It's a whole tool kit, which
means, as they say, bear markets
become feeding frenzies.
Bowls are just as tasty for the
pros who get the stuff.
The sources basically say
there's no better place on earth
to be.
Which naturally leads to the
other side.
What about the average person in
all this?
The mark in the casino analogy.
Yeah, this is where the sources
get pretty blunt and honestly, a
bit bleak.
They say for the average person
saving for retirement, it's
terrifying.
You know they're told this
standard advice.
Buy and hold long term strategy.
Right, that's what you always
hear.
But in this kind of volatile
setup, what often happens
instead, according to the
sources, is they end up doing
the opposite.
They buy high, sell low and
watch their portfolios shrink
because there's this huge
disconnect.
They just don't see what the
trolls are doing.
They don't see the hedge funds
feasting on the swings because
they don't even know the swings
can be monetized.
So it comes down to a massive
knowledge gap, a lack of
understanding of how the casino
actually works.
Exactly.
The sources put it very starkly.
These average people are the
chips in the pot, not the
players.
They're the entertainment for
the pros and crucially, and it's
not their fault, they were never
told the rules.
The casino was designed that
way.
That really emphasizes the idea
that the game isn't just hard,
it's fundamentally opaque for
most participants.
And they use IQ stats to kind of
illustrate this point, right,
Though they say it's a rough
measure.
Yeah.
It's less about pure
intelligence and more about
specialized financial literacy,
I think is the point They
mentioned, you know, maybe only
10% clear 120 IQ, maybe 2% hit
130.
But the underlying principle is
and most of the players don't
even understand the game.
They don't get the tools.
Right.
They don't know how derivatives
work.
They don't know what shorting
is.
They don't know why volatility
is a product to be sold.
They lack that specific crucial
knowledge about how these
complex markets operate.
So what happens when most people
are playing blind?
Well, the sources say they play
blind and the casino loves it.
The hustlers love it.
The pros love it.
It's an environment where that
lack of knowledge isn't just a
disadvantage, it's actually
profitable for those who do
know.
And they end that thought with
this really cutting image.
America's marketplace is
populated by whales who think
they're sharks.
Whales thinking they're sharks.
And the real sharks are happy to
let them believe it.
It's about self deception really
and how it fused the whole
system.
That is potent, the whales who
think they're sharks.
What really stands out to you
there?
Because it really paints a
picture of these power dynamics,
doesn't it?
It really does.
It suggests a system where it's
not just that most people are
losing, it's that they're
misunderstanding.
They're thinking they're playing
the game effectively is exactly
what makes them valuable to the
game.
It transforms the economy from,
you know, a place of exchange to
this, this grand spectacle,
almost a financial ecosystem
built to extract value from the
unaware. 3 The global angle.
America, the world's open
Buffett.
OK.
So building on America as this
sort of unregulated, maybe
uniquely designed casino, the
sources then widen the lens.
Looking at it globally, they
draw this really interesting
contrast with other major
economies.
They point out how, you know,
the EU protects its markets, how
Germany uses things like VAT and
tariffs to fund social programs,
how Japan tends to keep
outsiders at arm's length.
It paints this picture of other
nations actively using policy
tools, regulations, taxes, maybe
protectionism to kind of guard
their own interests, control
capital flows, keep wealth
generated inside or at least
make it contribute domestically.
But America, it's presented as
completely different.
Totally different.
The sources describe it as just
wide open, like.
Imports flood in with almost no
resistance.
Tariffs are low to non existent.
Yeah.
So this openness which is often
framed as, you know, a good
thing, free markets and all
that, right?
In this casino analogy, it's
reframed as a huge
vulnerability, like an open
invitation for global players to
just come in and take value
without much friction.
So like a leaving the casino
doors unlocked and unguarded.
Pretty much, yeah.
And it's not just goods coming
in freely, it's about the
consumer base too, right?
Right.
They argue America has built a
consumer base so hungry, so
flush with credit, that global
corporations use us as their
playground.
So it's not just a strong
economy, it's almost like the
perfect target market.
That's the implication, that the
sheer buying power, the easy
credit, makes American consumers
irresistible.
And these global players,
companies from other countries,
they essentially dump their
products here, reap the profits
and take the chips home.
So it's presented less like fair
trade, more like a one way
extraction of wealth.
Profits made here get sent
elsewhere.
Yeah, that's the core argument
there, which.
Leads them to this really
direct, pretty provocative
statement.
America is not running the
casino.
It is the casino.
The world plays here.
It's not just the location, it's
the game itself.
And they call it the world's
most naive casino.
Naive because.
Because they say fraud is
rampant, hustling is rampant,
misrepresentation is normal.
There's this sense of weak
oversight, a kind of
permissiveness, and that idea
again, that the House, the
supposed regulator, is asleep.
Sounds less like a market, more
like a free for.
All Yeah.
Which is why the warning isn't
just buyer beware.
It's gambler beware.
Caveat emptor becomes gambler
beware.
And the pros know this, but the
average person, the whale,
doesn't.
Exactly.
The pros know it, the whales
don't.
That information asymmetry,
again, most people don't even
realize the nature of the game
they're in.
They think it's just normal
economic life.
The sources say most of the
people walking into the casino
don't even realize they're in
one.
They think they're high rollers,
but they're the marks.
Is she right back to that power
imbalance, that gap in
understanding?
And they wrap it up with that
old poker saying yeah.
If you can't spot the sucker in
the room, it's you.
And the punchline?
In this global game, America is
the sucker.
That's that's a really strong
claim to position America,
despite its economic size, as
the primary target for global
players who understand the rules
better.
It is, and it really reframes
things, doesn't it?
Beyond just trade deficits or
debt, it suggests a kind of
structural vulnerability, a
design that favors savvy
outsiders.
Which then leads to the next big
question.
If all this wealth is being
generated and extracted, where
does it actually go?
And what's the impact on the
country itself for the
uncollected winnings, where the
profits go?
Yeah, that's a huge question the
sources dig into.
If you have these trillions just
swirling around all this wealth
being pulled out of the casino,
where does it land?
And Paradox they highlight is
that despite all this activity,
the state collects almost
nothing from this chaos.
So massive economic turn, but
very little benefit to the
public purse.
That's the argument.
It just seems to bypass the
mechanisms for public revenue
collection.
And why is that?
What are the reasons they give?
Well, they point to systemic
issues, loopholes, ways to avoid
taxes, things baked into the
financial system.
Like they say, income taxes are
full of loopholes.
You know, deductions, shelters,
ways for people with good advice
to reduce their burden
significantly.
Standard stuff for high earners,
maybe.
Right.
And then corporations offshore
their profits, that classic move
where companies shift profits on
paper to low tax countries.
So the money made from US
customers isn't actually taxed
much in the US, if at all.
OK.
And for the Super wealthy, is it
even more sophisticated?
According to the sources, yes.
They explain how capital gains
are taxed only when realized,
meaning only when you actually
sell an asset like stock or
property.
Right.
But critically, the ultra rich
can borrow against their assets
indefinitely to avoid
realization.
Can you break that down a bit?
How does borrowing avoid the
tax?
Sure.
So imagine you own billions in
stock.
Instead of selling it and paying
a huge capital gains tax, you go
to a bank and take out massive
loans, using that stock as
collateral.
The loan money you receive is an
income, so it's not taxed.
You can live off that borrowed
money while your original assets
hopefully keep growing in value.
You never realize the gain by
selling, so you never trigger
the tax.
It's a perfectly legal way to
access wealth without it ever
hitting the tax system.
Keeps the money inside the
financial machinery not flowing
out to the government.
Wow, OK, that's a powerful
mechanism.
So if the state isn't collecting
much of this money, where does
it end up?
Well, the sources are pretty
clear.
The trillions that swirl through
the casino never touched the
social fabric.
It doesn't translate into public
good.
It doesn't fund social programs.
It just stays within the
financial system.
Pretty much, they say.
It tends to inflate the paper
wealth of those who can play and
evaporate the savings of those
who can't.
It sounds like a 0 sum game or
maybe worse for the majority who
are on the losing side.
And the implications for society
are huge then?
Absolutely, the sources argue.
These massive revenue streams,
these profits from the casino,
they don't flow to universal
healthcare, free education,
housing or the other services
people claim to want.
The things societies usually
fund with taxes.
Exactly.
Instead, the money stays locked
in the machinery, feeding more
bets so it becomes a self
feeding cycle.
Profits for speculation just
fuel more speculation, more
financial engineering, more
volatility.
Rather than being used to build,
you know, infrastructure or
safety Nets, the capital stays
circulating among the players,
reinforcing the casino itself V
the hedge.
A politically poisoned solution?
OK, so given that stark picture,
wealth flowing out, not
benefiting the public, the
sources then turn to potential
solutions, or at least ways to
maybe harness some of this
chaos, right?
Yeah, they suggest it's not
inevitable that all of this
chaos could actually be
harnessed.
Implying the current setup could
be changed.
Right.
And they propose a very specific
tool for doing that.
They say tariffs would be the
hedge against this.
Tariffs would be the only clean
way to extract revenue from the
madness.
Tariffs.
OK, why tariffs specifically?
What benefits do they outline?
Well, several.
First, they argue tariffs hit at
the border.
They're unavoidable, meaning
they're harder to dodge with
clever accounting or offshoring
compared to, say, income or
corporate taxes.
They get collected right as
goods enter.
Simpler collection maybe What?
Else Second, they claim tariffs
could fund the state without
chasing ghosts or taxing
paychecks, so a more direct
revenue stream may be less
reliant on complex income tax
systems with all the loopholes.
Third, they suggest tariffs
could slow the churn, protect
domestic producers and make
services fundable.
OK.
So generating revenue and
potentially helping local
industry by making imports more
expensive.
That's the idea, a dual benefit.
And finally, maybe most
importantly, in this whole
casino analogy, they argue
tariffs would stop the casino
from being an open buffet for
everyone else.
We would kind of close off that
wide open door we talked about
making it harder for global
players to just extract wealth
without contributing back.
OK, presented like that, it
sounds, well, almost like a neat
solution to the problems they've
described.
It does sound logical in that
context.
But there's always a but isn't
there?
There is the source is
immediately pivot, but tariffs
are politically poisoned.
OK, so the problem isn't
necessarily the economics, it's
the politics.
That's exactly what they focus
on here.
They pinpoint why it's poisoned.
Trump like them so half the
country hates them, even if
they're the only way to get the
utopia they say they want.
Wow.
That's quite the statement on
political polarization.
It is, it highlights this deep
irony, a potential tool which
these sources are you could
fundamentally shift things.
Is basically off the table.
Not because of economic debate
about pros and cons, which
definitely exists for tariffs.
Right.
Economists have debated tariffs
forever.
But here the sources are saying
the primary block is just its
association with one political
figure.
Exactly.
It's dismissed out of hand by
many because of who championed
it, regardless of whether it
might actually achieve goals
those same people might support,
like funding social programs or
protecting workers.
That's a fascinating and kind of
depressing paradox.
A potential solution neutralized
by politics.
Yeah, and the result, according
to the sources.
Instead, the casino stays wide
open and the marks keep walking
in.
The cycle continues.
The open buffet remains open
because the tool to potentially
close it is politically
untouchable for many.
Precisely.
What stands out to you about
that dynamic?
Is it just partisanship?
Or maybe does it hint that maybe
the people who benefit from the
current open system are quite
happy to see potential changes
get bogged down in politics?
That's a really sharp question.
It could be both, right?
Deep partisan divides make it
easy to dismiss ideas, but it
could also serve the interests
of those who like the casino
just the way it is.
A politically poisoned solution
is effectively no solution at
all.
Six The magic trick.
Perception versus reality.
Which kind of leads us perfectly
into what the sources call
America's ultimate magic trick.
It's not just that the casino
exists or how it works, it's
that it convinces everyone
they're winning.
The grand Illusion.
Yeah, the thing that keeps the
whole game going, like in a real
casino, right?
The lights keep flashing, the
music keeps playing, the chips
keep sliding.
Sensory overload.
Distraction.
Exactly.
It keeps you from looking too
closely at how the odds are
really stacked.
And the sources breakdown how
this illusion works for
different people.
Like the average person, the
mark thinks the free drink is a
gift, not a distraction.
They focus on the superficial
stuff, maybe cheap goods, easy
credit, maybe their four O 1K
went up last quarter.
Right, the immediate visible
things.
Yeah, while missing the bigger
picture, the systemic extraction
that's happening underneath,
focusing on the little wins,
ignoring the house edge.
And even people who seem to be
doing OK might be fooled.
That's what they suggest.
The investors think they're
beating the market because their
portfolios are green this
quarter.
They see some short term
success, a good run, and
convince themselves they figured
it out.
That they're sharks, not whales.
Exactly, unaware of the deeper
structure that ensures the
House, or rather the real pros,
win overtime.
And even the politicians.
They think they're running the
show, but they're just another
card in the deck.
Also just players in a bigger
game they don't fully control.
Yeah, their actions often just
end up perpetuating the system,
even if they think they're
reforming it.
It suggests the casino has a
life of its own.
So if everybody thinks they're
winning, or at least in control,
who are the real winners here?
The sources pull back the
curtain for the final reveal.
The real winners are the ones
who built the game, the ones who
know how to bet on every spin,
the ones who profit whether the
wheel lands on red or black.
The architects, the masters of
the game.
Right.
They don't care about individual
outcomes as long as the game
itself continues, as long as
there's volatility, as long as
the mechanisms for extracting
profit are still in place.
And this leads to that final
kind of chilling take away about
America's actual role.
Yeah, the conclusion is stark.
Yeah, America is not America's
casino.
It's the world's.
Not run for America, but run as
a global playground.
Exactly.
They summarize it as the place
where lead turns to gold, where
volatility itself is a
commodity, where every crisis is
another jackpot.
Every event, every shock, every
downturn.
It's just more fuel for the
fire, more opportunity for those
who truly understand how to
play.
And the ultimate punchline.
The joke, as they call it.
Is that we think we're running
it or not.
We're the table, we're the
sucker and we keep spinning the
wheel because that's what the
casino was built to make us do.
It just drives home that feeling
of involuntary participation,
the power of the illusion, the
way the system just keeps itself
going regardless of who thinks
they're in charge.
So what does this all mean for
you, listening to this?
I mean, it's more than just a
clever metaphor, isn't it?
It's a really stark way of
looking at global economics,
where the line between a nation
and just a giant financial
machine gets really blurry.
And maybe understanding the
game, just knowing the rules as
described here, is the absolute
first step, Maybe the only first
step you can take to navigate it
differently, or maybe eventually
to think about changing it.
We've definitely gone deep today
into this, this fascinating,
maybe pretty unsettling idea.
America as the world's casino,
where volatility isn't the
problem, it's the product, and
where maybe many of us are
playing without knowing the real
stakes.
These sources really push us to
look past the bright lights,
past the noise, and ask who
really benefits from all the
chaos and how this whole game is
actually designed.
So maybe the thought to leave
you with is this, if America is
this global casino and if you
now have a clearer picture based
on these sources of the rules,
the players, the way it works,
what is that awareness actually
empower you to do?
How might it change how you
navigate the economy yourself,
how you consume information, how
you think about your own
financial situation?
Is just knowing the game enough
to actually change your odds?
Where does it demand something
more fundamental in how we think
about our participation in this,
this huge global gamble?